i want to talk today about the phrase
trump derangement syndrome i've tweeted
about this
a few times and chauncey de vega wrote a
really good article about this on salon
which i tweeted yesterday
called there was no trump derangement
syndrome we were right about him
all along so let's talk about this trump
derangement syndrome
is a bad faith phrase which is meant to
shut down debate
stop conversation and excuse donald
trump's atrocious
behavior now i know that there will
certainly be some of you who will
respond to me and say you know david
look
check out this person on twitter who is
irrationally obsessed with everything
trump does and they think anything bad
in the world is trump's doing
this person is suffering from trump
derangement syndrome
listen you you can find instances of
everything on the internet but we're not
dealing in anecdotes here
the problem systemically with the phrase
trump derangement syndrome is that its
use is very
similar to what regressive left became a
couple of years ago i don't know if you
remember this
but regressive left much like trump
derangement syndrome are phrases that
are used to shut down debate
by disqualifying and dismissing
criticism
without actually having to debate the
merits of the criticism so
let's first really dig in i want
everybody to get this
what do people mean by trump derangement
syndrome the idea of tds
as it's sometimes called is to use it as
a retort
when someone criticizes donald trump
someone says look
trump did this trump's not responsible
for 160 000 deaths but he's responsible
for some because it's been one of the
worst responses to the virus
in the world you have trump derangement
syndrome and
what they mean by that is you are so
blinded by your hatred of donald trump
that we can dismiss
what you are saying without examining it
because you're just blinded by
by your rage against donald trump so
think back to the term regressive left
there was this very
very brief period where the term
regressive left
was sort of interesting in that it was
used to describe instances of ostensible
or supposed leftists failing to actually
be on the left in their views and
typically what what you had was
instances of people who claim to be on
the left being authoritarian and in a
sense it was a useful term for a very
short period of time and very quickly
the term regressive left
was bastardized and perverted by the
right and it became a catch-all
insult that they used to basically say
you're on the left and i don't like what
you have to say
i don't like what you're saying because
it's left wing and regressive left lost
all value as as any kind of a useful
tool
to explore failing to be on the left
trump derangement syndrome is equally
meaningless with the
important difference that unlike
regressive left trump derangement
syndrome
never actually described a real thing it
was always bogus there was a brief
period where regressive left actually
was an interesting
term to describe something i had been
talking about for for many years
which are instances of the authoritarian
left failing to really be on the left
but with each passing day the most
serious concerns about donald trump that
were expressed by people
on the left like me have been proven to
be true and they've been proven to be
true horrifyingly so remember that
months ago joe biden was widely
ridiculed for suggesting
you know trump might try to create some
kind of pretext an emergency of some
kind
to delay the election trump uh uh did
that
days ago by tweeting maybe we do need to
delay the election
joe biden was ridiculed and said he was
you know people were saying he has trump
derangement syndrome
he was right years ago people raised the
alarm
about donald trump's authoritarian
tendencies sort of he wants to be a
he's a wannabe dictator and over the
last month we have seen
him send armed paramilitaries to
american cities
to throw people into unmarked vans and
as chauncey de vega points out
points out in the article that we're
linking to which you should read quote
this was a phrase used to demean mock
reject
dismiss and deflect warnings about
donald trump's beliefs and tendencies
and those who were trying to raise the
alarm were called again as chauncey says
hysterical alarmist or out of touch
and bitter about hillary clinton's loss
if you encounter the phrase trump
derangement syndrome on the internet on
twitter
in real life maybe anywhere don't allow
yourself to be bullied into silence by
it
they claim on the right that they're all
about conversation
and yet this entire idea of trump
derangement syndrome is meant to stop
conversation make it clear that calling
someone a victim
of trump derangement syndrome is not
really an argument
say i'm glad to talk about that which
facts did i get wrong i'm glad to change
my views if you tell me what i got wrong
trump derangement syndrome is not an
argument it's a smoke screen it tries to
put us on the defensive
but the real derangement is the more
than 60 million people nearly 63 million
people who voted for donald trump in
2016 tens of millions of whom plan to
vote for him again
in just months that's the real
derangement
the horrifying nature of this presidency
which will be
affirmed by 50 60 65
67 million people who plan to vote for
it again
in november if there is any valid
criticism of those
like me on the anti-trump side it's that
we didn't do enough to raise the alarm
prior to him being elected as much as i
tried now
of course the people who are primarily
to blame are the people who
fell for it and voted for trump but if
you want to make a criticism of the
anti-trump left
that is to be taken more seriously
criticize us for something real
which is that as much as many of us were
trying to warn people
even we might have underestimated the
risks of the presidency
that's the reality trump derangement
syndrome don't allow it to be used
to silence actual critiques of this
president which if anything
have been not uh alarmist enough
let me know your thoughts i'm on twitter
at deepakman and remember you can get
the daily audio podcast
every day 3 pm eastern on your favorite
podcasting app whichever one it may be